MALE SPEAKER: Be even
better if it moved.
MALE SPEAKER: It would be.
MALE SPEAKER: You ready?
THIJS DAMSMA: OK, I'm
ready, I guess.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Take it away.
THIJS DAMSMA: OK.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for tuning in.
This is my presentation
about visualization of
coastal data with KML.
My name is Thijs Damsa, and
I've done this work for
EcoShape last summer.
And all the work I've done is
available on openearth.eu.
First little bit, this is going
to be about data from
the Netherlands.
That's where I'm from.
Netherlands is a low-lying
country.
And we basically owe our
existence to coastal zone
management.
If we wouldn't manage our
coastal zone, the sea would
have taken out at least
half of the country.
So that's why in the Netherlands
coastal protection
is very important.
Now, within the Netherlands we
have this new thing, EcoShape,
Building with Nature, that's a
collaborative research program
for integrated coastal
zone management.
So just a bunch of companies
and institutes who work
together, put up some money, and
basically do more research
about the coast.
And of course, Building with
Nature indicates that it's all
sustainable nowadays, just like
everything has to be.
Now, within EcoShape we have a
thing called OpenEarth Tools.
And that's the geeky part of
it, the technicalities to
facilitate the research.
When many people do a lot of
research, you need some
technical infrastructure
to help you out.
So OpenEarth Tools is all
about managing data.
Because basically research, or
the research we do, is mostly
about managing data.
So it's collecting data, getting
it from whatever
institute owns it.
Then we collect it.
We store the data.
We put it in manageable
format.
We put everything in that CDF.
Process the data, so do whatever
you want with it, and
then present the data to
whoever's your audience.
So that's the research cycle.
And one of the basic things we
want to do, we want to collect
all the data available.
Because nowadays in research
it's usually you spend a lot
of time collecting your data,
finding out who owns it, where
is it, how is it stored, which
format is it in, and how do I
get that into whatever computer
program you use to
process it.
Also another thing we do next to
collecting and storing data
is sharing tools.
So we don't want to reinvent
the wheel every time, so
everybody is encouraged to
share as much of their
programming with other people as
possible, so everybody can
use and work on each
other's tools.
We have a subversion repository
with scripts.
A lot of it is in Matlab,
because that's where a lot of
coastal researchers are familiar
with, but also
Python, Fortran, whatever
you can put in there.
And the participation is,
of course, important.
More is better.
So you have to have an
attractive thing that
everybody feels encouraged to
sign up on and to work with.
Now that's where it gets
a bit complicated.
Because not everyone
is a programmer.
And if you explain these kind
of sheets with how we manage
data, how we process it, how we
have different servers to
do everything, for a lot of
people, especially the
non-technical, the
non-programmers, it's just
basically a bunch of [INAUDIBLE]
mumbo jumbo.
And they don't really know what
you're talking about or
what the advantages are of
joining your program.
So the important thing
is a visualization.
And this is a scan of
a book which is--
every year they bring out the
new book which shows some
coastal data from
the Netherlands.
They have a map.
You have some green bars, which
are good, and you have
red bars, which are bad.
But it's a book, so you have to
print a new one every year.
And it's not interactive.
So it's a really kind
of static thing.
And this is how it's
done nowadays.
And of course we want
more things.
So another way to present your
data is, of course, in
computer programs.
But you usually get plots
like this or like
this, or like this.
And usually you kind of
miss the context of
what the data means.
And it's not always that
appealing, so I'd say it's
kind of ugly.
And it's good for some purposes,
but as an attractive
way of presenting your
results, it's
maybe not that good.
Because it's all very static.
And still you don't get
user interaction.
Or if you do want it, you have
to develop a user interface.
And those are expensive
to develop.
And it's difficult to do that
in a proper and nice way.
So we have another thing, and
that's called Google Earth.
We use Google Earth to present
our data and as sort of a
visual front-end for the
databases we've created.
We're experiencing now how we
can use Google Earth to its
maximum to interact with the
data and to present it.
So this is--
I want to give you a live
demonstration of the Google
Earth stuff I've done.
So switch to Google Earth.
And I'll just pull up a chair.
OK, so first let's go
to the Netherlands.
So fly here.
Netherlands, it's a country
right down here.
Amsterdam, the capital.
First I'll show you a data
set which we only
recently got hold of.
It's a Dutch heights, so it's
like a datum of the country.
And this is a tiled image I've
generated using the tools we
have, which show the height
of the country.
Now here's the coloring, which
more or less indicates the
natural beach color.
So blue is underwater,
submerged, and green is above.
And sandy is sort
of beach level.
So if I just switch it off,
you'll see that a lot of the
country is actually colored
blue, which indicates that
it's pretty much below
sea level.
And you'd reduce the size of
the country by about 50% if
there were no sea protections.
So just to give you a bit of an
idea why we think coastal
protection so important
in the Netherlands.
The good thing is you can use
Google Earth to present data
which you would otherwise
also present.
But if you look at the
resolution of this map, it's
actually pretty high.
And if you print this out,
you'll have a huge map.
And if you're only interested
in a little bit, well, then
you need a lot of small maps.
But that's really
inconvenient.
So this is a big advantage of
Google Earth, just being able
to zoom interactively.
It dynamically loads data
when it needs to.
So quickly you can get a good
overview of your data.
There's much more
possibilities.
And I'll show you a little thing
we've made of Katrina
the hurricane.
This is a little animation
of the hurricane.
The water levels are indicated
by the coloring.
So the Gulf of Mexico and the
arrows indicate the wind.
So I'll just play this.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
THIJS DAMSMA: Needs to load
a little bit more.
So it's needs a bit time to load
the background images.
But as I scroll through,
get a bit smoother.
And you see here all the arrows
indicating how the
hurricane has developed and how
the wind pushed the water.
And here you can really see
clearly how the wind pushed
the water all through
New Orleans.
So you can understand why New
Orleans was so badly hit.
Because just before the
hurricane reached the shore,
the water levels said
it wasn't that bad.
And really, as it progressed
closely to the shore--
here you see it--
it really pushed the water
all the way up to
the back of the city.
And that's why we got so
much damage there.
So you can use Google Earth to
make simple animations and
just look through
them as you go.
And if you have a map any other
way, of course it's
really hard to get this level of
user interaction where you
can just scroll through your
data just like that.
So this is one of the things
I'd like to show you.
In the Netherlands we
have an estuary.
It's called the Westerschelde.
It's down here in the bottom.
And this is a harbor
of Antwerp.
So there's a lot of shipping
from down this corner all up
to the sea.
But as it's an estuary you
need to do a lot of
maintenance to make sure
it's deep enough.
So there's a lot
of maps of it.
So first I'll show a
bathymetric map of this estuary.
I'll just change the angle.
And a good thing of Google Earth
is that you can easily
compare different data sets
if you at least treat
them in the same way.
So the one I'll first show you,
the height data set of
the Netherlands, this is
a different source.
And you see immediately if I
just pop it on and off that in
the estuary you get basically
the same data, but it's
slightly different.
So if you're really interested
in it, you could check it out,
why is the data different.
But at least visually you can
get a quick impression that
there's different data,
different sources, that
they're not always identical,
of course.
Now, you can use traditional
quiver plots to plot the flow.
Because a simulation was done
here, so using advanced
modeling, a simulation was done
of the tidal flows and
the speeds of the water
which you get.
So at a certain time, these
arrows represent the flow you
have in your estuary.
And of course, static arrows,
that's something
maybe of the past.
So you want to have the flow,
and have the flow dynamically.
So let me just load that.
It takes a sec.
And now if I look through it,
you get a much better
indication of where
you have the flow.
And you see at the deep parts
you have redder, bigger arrows
moving faster, so that indicates
a strong flow.
And with a downgoing tide,
all the water flows back.
And you can see it really
follows the gullies and gives
you a good indication of where
the flow is and what the
important areas are, and gives
you a nice way to disseminate
the results of a computational
model within the public in a
way that they can actually
play with it.
Because I just press the play
button here, but of course you
can also drag different time
steps or maybe if you enhance
the slide, you can get
more of a history--
let's say a particle
tracking way of how
the flow has developed.
Now, all these computations
were done on a certain
computational grid.
It's also a good thing to note
that in Google Earth, you see
here all the black indicates
the grid, and all the--
these are all grid cells.
So it also gives you a good
indication of which resolution
you can achieve and how this
lines up with, for instance, a
satellite image.
So lines up pretty good,
but not perfectly.
So this is the computational
grid which we have used.
It gives you an idea of the
scale and the size of what you
could achieve.
Now, another way of presenting
the depth would be using a
contour plot.
So I'll also use
contours here.
But as Google Earth 3D,
why not make the
contour plot in 3D?
So this is what I've done.
Gives you nice 3D
contour plot.
But unfortunately, the digital
terrain model's not user
adjustable, which means that I
have to plot something which
is underwater.
I have to lift it up above the
ground and then exaggerate the
height of it to get an
indication of how deep the
gullies are.
So you can really see the
really steep edges here.
Let's go down here.
Now I could add some
labels here.
A good thing about Google Earth
is I don't have to worry
about all my labels
clogging up.
Because as I zoom out, it
will draw less labels.
Always make each individual
label visual.
Now also, I could combine
this with the grid
I just showed you.
And then you really get a nice
indication of the 3D grid,
which is created to do
these model runs.
So this is basically a powerful
visualization which
you could never achieve
in any other way.
The other data set which I've
put in here is called the
Dutch Beach Lines.
Gives an indication of dune foot
and shoreline positions
throughout the years.
And I'll just zoom in to one
of these islands here.
And the data goes back--
this is 1842.
And as soon as these lines pop
up, that's where I have
measurement data available.
So the blue line indicates
the shoreline,
the edge of the beach.
And the green line, the dune
foots are where the beach goes
over in the dunes.
As I scroll through that, you
really get an indication of
how this island has changed
throughout the years, where it
grows, where it erodes.
And this can help the general
public understand what's
natural variations or what are
artificial ones, and where you
should be worried about
or what not.
It just really gives a quick
view of what you can expect.
And also, if you make it broader
this side where you
get an idea of the variation.
So it's normal that you
have a few meters of
variations at points.
And if you want to measure, you
can just use a ruler tool
here and see how many meters or
feet of variations you have
throughout a certain
time span.
So this is really something
which can help out a lot.
And I've also plotted out the
grid over which these lines
are measured, just to
give an indication.
Now, other data sets have
also been created.
This is called a [INAUDIBLE]
data set.
It's only available from
1960 something.
Here it is.
And these are coastal profile
measurements of the dunes.
Now, normally these are
profiles-- you would
draw them in a plot.
But here I thought, why not plot
them in 3D just over the
map, which, over the satellite
picture, gives you a good idea
of these different data sets,
what context they are made in.
Now, a powerful interpretation
of this is all these lines
which you see here,
they all seem to
represent dune profile.
You can't see by a line that
actually this line is nonsense
and that line is nonsense
and that one is good.
But you can see from the context
that you see on this
satellite picture.
Let me just illustrate
this to you.
So here you see dune profiles
from year to year.
See also how the profiles
influence where the beaches
and where not.
I see the blue and green lines
moving back and forth.
But also you see the lines here
on the right side jagging
very much from year to year.
And I'll just expand the time
span which I'm viewing.
And you see here that there are
really big variations of
the dune profile in here
also from year to year.
And if you just look at the
satellite picture, you
immediately understand
why-- because this
is not a dune profile.
This is actually a coal stack
of some kind of big
factory over here.
But they are included
in the data.
And if you don't have the
context, there's no way to
know, except if you very closely
study the data, you
ask some questions.
But here you can just easily
have a glance at your data,
just fly over it.
And those things, they become
clear pretty quickly
what's going on.
So the next data set, the last
one I want to show you, is
called [INAUDIBLE],
a Dutch word.
But it means basically height
maps which are measured from
year to year at different
locations.
They're all stored in
different charts.
And if I go to this location,
I've taken some metadata from
the database, which
is behind this.
And it just gives a really--
it's a quick way to look at
metadata, even though I didn't
put very much in here.
But you can see the
coordinates of the
measurements and whatever
information you
want to show here.
You can see the years on
which it's measured.
And on a few years I've
pre-rendered some charts.
And I'd like to show you one.
You could click on the links,
but I've already
loaded them in here.
So this is a 3D map of,
actually, what's the data.
This is from 2005.
So I also used KMLs.
I directly plot a
three-dimensional image of the
measurement.
I colored it and triangulated
it.
So this gives an idea of the
area which is measured.
And of course, you could
load data from
several different points.
Just click on it, and then
you can really make your
own map as you go.
Another one which is important,
I've created this
time animation.
So all the different
data which is
stored at this point--
let me just load everything.
Might take a sec.
OK, there, it's coming.
And now you see how the profiles
have changed in time.
They seem getting nothing much
changed, because it hasn't
been measured that frequently.
In the later years you can see
how the coast has changed.
So I'll just do it myself.
You get a good idea
of how the coastal
evolution is of this area.
Also, you notice in the
back in, say, 1980,
there's hardly any bumps.
It's a very smooth
bathymetric map.
But in later years there's
a lot more detail.
Of course, the topography
probably hasn't changed.
But it's more that the
measurements have changed.
So it's probably multi-beam
EcoSound instead of
single-beam, which gives
you more detail.
But you can quickly compare
all these maps, and really
easily you get an idea
of the changes which
have occurred in time.
So small wrap-up--
if you use Google Earth
as a visual
front-end for your database--
oh, I see I'm out
of the screen.
MALE SPEAKER: Just
stay seated.
THIJS DAMSMA: So if you use
Google Earth as a visual
front-end of a database, first
thing is it looks good and
everyone can use it.
I just showed you in a live
demonstration, which went
almost flawless-- no but--
everyone can use it.
Google Earth is a user-friendly
program.
I think Google put a lot of
effort in making it easy for
everyone to use, no complicated
menus and no
complicated installation
procedures, and-- good thing--
no license fees.
It works on a lot of
operating systems.
You have lots of
possibilities.
You can make it interactive.
You can use four dimensions,
three dimensional plus time.
This is a huge advantage over
most other data viewers.
So to wrap it up, Google Earth
can be used as a visual
front-end for the data in
OpenEarth and, I think, for
many other data sets.
One big wish I have for KML is
that I could use an adjustable
DTM so that I could adjust the
terrain model without having
to make complicated 3D overlays
and be able to dig a
hole in the earth to show my own
data instead of have the
data as it is now, that
I have to raise
everything up from the earth.
Now, OpenEarth tools, everything
I've shown here is
created with Matlab.
Its source code, the
documentation, and tutorials
to use this is freely
available.
So you just go to openearth.eu
and you'll
find everything there.
So thank you for
your attention.
[APPLAUSE]